all right emilio
emilio where'd you grow up where are you
from originally
i'm from puerto rico
and tell me about your family growing up
you had both your parents
no
they they take me off
dhs just got me because my my mom and my
dad used to get high and
and you know treat me right yeah so your
parents lost you where did you go then
yeah
after that who who raised you
uh
i
i really say the truth they
fostered home no i don't grow up with my
family
but you're just different families
taking care of different family yeah
that i remember they take me when i when
i'm little so
i don't remember that much but i i
really remember they they really take us
did you jump around from one family to
the next yeah
to a half to god 21 years old
how would you describe your childhood
how else how would you describe your
childhood in general
no good at all i don't got no never god
you just don't
did you ever feel loved as a child no
at all
i just i never feel never heard my dad
and my mom told me
that they love me something
so
it's hard man yeah
you came to the united states when
you came to the united states yeah i
came to united states
21 december 2nd
2005
came to camden new jersey with my dad
camden yeah then i meet my dad after 12
after years oh really yeah i came i came
to to camden
and then i i started working all that
stuff how was it meeting your father
meet him you met your father you said
when you came hey how was that
so it's so so nice but in the same time
it just
it's so normal because i never grow up
with him so i just see him like a
like a normal person i don't even
it's crazy like
i don't really feel that love for my
it's not he don't raise me so
but then i just started doing wrong
doing all these drugs from him
with your dad with my dad yeah catching
him in there in there
in the bathroom getting high so i asked
him you say you
this is great you want to taste it so i
just got high
and after that
my mom you know i have to come over here
to
get a job and do better
i left him alone over there came with my
baby mom and my kids
and then i just
bought again he came across the river to
philadelphia
how long you been in kensington
yo i came in kensington when i
2007
june
so i got like 15 years
i'm gonna say 15 years
how was kensington changed oh my god
it's bad it just get worse and worse
every ball every day really
bad like
it's so bad to the limit that i said yo
this is over man
i'm serious man i can deal with that
this is so hard man that i feel like i
got a full
job it's just feel like that
and you're living on the streets
in the streets yeah because i want to
doing him because i really just can't do
right man people i got a couple people
that really helped me but he just got
blind on me like
it's crazy what is your drug what has
been your drug i used to do a fentanyl
powder
and i used to do hard too
but i'm really i'm really in sebastian
right now i feel so happy i'm doing okay
oh good for you
it's just hard but how would you support
yourself
living on the street i'll be i'll be
i'll be doing
you know cleaning jars so i'll be doing
i got people to help me man and i don't
really
i'm okay but what do you really do to
make money
yeah
you know i do my things man right
i know
i can use my imagination uh-huh
and your kids do you see your kids
i seen him and
i don't see him for like a couple years
since 2017 i don't see my kids but i
seen in a phone i talked to them
i started talking to them they impr yeah
yeah
everything okay
you don't see yourself going back to
puerto rico
that's what we're talking about they
told me that i wanted to go with them
and my baby mom you want to go back i'm
thinking him
they go back so i'm waiting for my
paperwork
because i lost my my wallet with all my
stuff in there
i got id i just have to take the
duplicate that's so have you tried
getting clean before
yes
how many times but with pressure
we pressured on him i tried a lot of
times i forgot i lost the count
and i never can make it bro it just it's
just hard man i'm scared of the sickness
man it's no joke
oh my god i go to the hospital almost
die that's no joke that's for anyone man
only anyone can hold that
they put there to just sleep the the
horde since all that kind of animals
they strong
that's bad and this is bad for your body
too
it's just crazy i see my body just
falling off pieces
forward everywhere i say no no and then
i can hit myself i don't know how to hit
oh crazy stuff man did i say i'm done
you tried to go cold turkey before
yes
and then that's the thing that i know
never going to tell us that i'm in my
i'm in my bag with that because i did it
myself without no pressing
yeah i didn't and then i always quit
with pressure on it
go to jail and then quit coming back out
and doing him
i can do whatever i want i got money in
my pockets i just don't want to
it's just not for me
i'll be smoking my weed and
you know do my things but not like that
nothing i'm going my veins and no
needles i feel better all my body
getting
replaced it back 16 years doing that
tell me about the tattoos you were in
gangs
um
in pr i used to be in a game
it's a group
january 21 25
81.
tell me about the street gangs in puerto
rico
yeah yeah that's yesterday they about to
man they they got every type of games
over there like 25 27
they got some landing kings all these
crazy games
what businesses do they get into drugs
mostly
yes
you know
yeah
street the street games you know
either gangs are worse than puerto rico
or here in the u.s
um big cities
yeah puerto rico i'm really serious they
take their over their series when i came
over here it's just weird like
they talking about is they don't run in
this over here and not be seeing him
it's not it's not running over here
that's a lot more hardcore in puerto
rico yeah over there they really running
it
you got some bosses they run up groups
and all that
yeah
what do you see for your future do you
have plans anything you like to do
sure yeah i'm really getting my mind
real every day i get real like motivated
about because i'm still in it in a
position that i don't feel that
healthy like i need to get weight on me
like it's no it's not it's not easy to
go through that i go into
but i really want to get it this is my
goal to get in my cdl license i like to
drive throws trucks
that's my that's my twist i love trucks
that's great yeah i love it man
and that's that's my one of my goals
right now you know i mean and i i know
how strong i can make it how old are you
i'm 36 36
it's good to have some kind of plan like
that yeah that's my my own goal right
now and i'll be loving it man
what's your biggest regret
what your biggest regret
i'm sorry that word
if you had your life to live all over
again what do you wish you had done
differently oh
i wish it done different
my school
never left the school how far did you go
in school eleven
i never fought as great eleventh grade
or eleventh grade
so almost high school you almost grew up
almost
and i never fought it great that's the
crazy stuff there and i'll be i don't
mean
i'd be suffering man
but i'm the ball bigger than the brain
you know john
you know i mean because
they take me
to houses
they're forcing homes and i'll be
missing school for a little bit
then they put me back on there and start
it over like you know what i mean
but i almost done it
that's the thing i'm gonna change you i
just have to go back and start over
i never leave to school
without school
you know
you can really make it like that
so that's one number thing one right
there but what emotions do you go
through do you get depressed or angry or
anxious or
yeah i really got ptsd
i got bad depression and i'll be taking
meds for that
because i got burned a house fire too
all my body's burned
you can see in him because he's got
clothes on it but
more you know my body just got burned on
my back my legs my face my hair
i did a lot of time in the hospital
trying to
call me back then i got shot after that
so yeah my body's really burned this
happened in puerto rico or over here
near the u.s yeah it happens 2015
february february 19
february 19
2015. when you were in kensington yeah
it happened on rounding in allegheny and
g
g and allegheny
you know corner used to be a chinese
store back in the day
yeah it's in the house and you go to the
alley and i came from jail clean i did
it back
and it's so dark and i put it go to buy
the candle came back put it in the floor
shoot go top of the candle and then
never take off burn my clothes burn the
whole house almost
and i can't believe it because see if
you get burned you're gonna jump
i got burned for half an hour like oh yo
it's just deep
he make a skin graft for me
takes king everywhere on my body to put
trying to put over here and then they
never
you never can fill it up that much
still got holes and stuff like that
yeah so man my legs is real skinny
you don't get weight
you know because it's just skin
burn like third first second degrees
my hands got burned trying to take the
fire out
it's just crazy like
so i just see fires and not getting
paranoid
what are you afraid of now what do you
what do you worry about
right now
i don't really
worry about nothing i just
i i just really
like to baby with my kids but
you know i take it easy
i have to put myself
right after that i do that because i
don't want to make my you know my little
junglers that suffer man
so i'm just putting myself together and
maybe take a couple months and i'm gonna
yeah take care of my people man
i was spending all those years on the
streets changed you you think
oh man
they shamed me a lot because i really
when i'm in that position i don't want
to be with
a lot of people
i i like to be by myself because
it just is crazy
it just changed me like i don't feel
love like that for
nobody like dad
it's just
my heart just speaks hard man
and this is just
don't care about nothing like
anything just make me happy
i'm just in drugs or numb
do you have any memories
as a child
any good memories of your childhood
i don't really remember that much that a
lot of stuff
i can't really say anything
i just yeah a couple stuff but
he just
i don't want to talk about that now it
just
do you think your life would have been
different if you had your parents and
yeah
a lot because this is real man the kids
need to dare him that amount it just
something that really
jungles me man
it's just different you be with somebody
that you don't really know it
and you just
that little you don't you don't know
like that
but you know you'll be growing up and
see what's going on what happened
and that that that's to her piece right
there man
never got it you know maybe there's
people that do my birthday but know my
people doing them like
like
christmas i never got you know nothing
from my mom my dad they steal my stuff
to sell it
that's what i remember
i really remember that
then my grandma passed away two thousand
and that's the one really take care of
me
since she passed away my life just
turned all the way around
stay with my dad in the same home and
for a little bit because after that they
take me from them
they got me back
yeah but they keep start doing the same
stuff again so they got us back like
three times happens
the four times they say you know what
it's over i'm taking it
from papers you can't you're never going
to have him
and that's what happens
i remember that
yeah
amelia what did you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
the less what's what's the most what's
the most important thing you've learned
in your life
like the more important thing that i've
learned in my life
i'm just saying
right
it's one thing that i'm gonna say is is
when you in this situation like this
it's don't really you found a lot of
like real people that know your teenage
situation so
it just
i don't know how to explain it man
i'm just
my mind go blank something for a little
bit
started thinking about stuff man it's
all right emilio thank you so much for
sharing your story yes i wish you the
best of luck with your suboxone
thank you my man good luck god bless you
have a nice day man love to see you
driving a truck man thank you my man
thanks
you